um how cool is
it to see Drake wearing y'all
[__] cuz because there first of all I
don't give a [__] what anybody says I
don't believe Drake wore
that having ever even heard any of our
music I think he wore that as a fashion
thing right okay I don't doubt that
because I think that's what's happening
I don't doubt over time you know we're
old school and you know you people you
know yeah I've seen in a fashion
magazine an ICP shirt for
$500 okay it was like ripped like it old
it was like a [__] fash vintage one
it was a vintage one huh no it was like
fashion it was the design of the shirt
you know say you need to get a piece
that's what I'm saying that like like
it's a it's a fashion thing get what I'm
saying like Drake had the was it the
Jersey huh was Drake wearing a jersey a
ring a a ring Master Jersey which is our
second album okay come on like like the
second Joker's card you
know what the [__] is Drake doing
wearing that but but I mean listen it's
got to feel kind of cool though let me
tell you something else that makes no
sense L Cool J right just did his tours
doing his tour right he has the wall
behind him what's on the wall have you
seen it bunch of names right yeah your
names on there my name just your name
just mine not Shaggy not ICP in the [__]
you know what I'm sayings like you're
complaining I've never met ll in my
[__] life I listen to his
station all day every day I've never
heard a blip of our [__] and we are 90s
to the [__] right core you know what
I'm saying right
and um I'm like why is my name on that
wall you know what I mean it makes no
[__] sense doesn't it you don't feel
like it's a it's dope to see you get
some acknowledgement all think it's like
an accident or like you know let me tell
you where I think it came from all right
what was the magazine does any Rudy was
it the New York Times or uh New York um
it was a it was a not a magazine a
newspaper right I think it was a
newspaper well you know it could also be
his graphic guy as a jug no I'm telling
you this newspaper came out and it did a
story the 50 greatest voices in Hip Hop
and so you're you you were on there and
they he asked I was on the list you know
what I'm saying and I was just like and
at the same time I would I did that
interview for that big newspaper yeah
you get what I'm saying um is when that
tour started and I saw my name on the
wall you know and I'm just like what the
[__] fu is going on with that you know I
mean they also might they could have
said ICP true you know what I'm saying
in in both true you know but for you
like I always like you said man like
when you think of jugal historically
it's the outcast of society it's people
you know a lot of people are from broken
homes a lot of you know most of the
people who I know um from a who were
jugal were were just that you know jug
come from Pain and it was never it was
never the cool thing to where it was
always like oh those are jug you know
but to have Drake who's like the biggest
rapper on the planet rocking your guys
as [__] it's almost crazy how Full
Circle that is like it's an honor you
know he's got like I don't remember but
it's
like 300 million followers or something
on on that do you guys see a spike in
merch sales 300 [__] million the
thing is it just looks cool though for
sure like it doesn't say I you guys had
really fly you guys really
another very well possibility he might
have fashion ninjas who work for him and
just give I got this Vint Jersey yeah
man or or just whatever you know you
ever heard you know he he just yeah I
just don't think it has anything to do
with our music what what kind of Pop was
that for you though did you guys see any
like Spike and merch sales no not that I
know you know everybody's mean Meed it
out in the jugler world I bet they have
and then post Malone too shout out to
post I think shout out to post knows who
you guys are huh he's got a post post
knows who shag Shaggy me post dope I
would love to meet post post is probably
one of my top three favorite artists yo
can you educate me right now oh post is
amazing you know I'm saying it's really
hard for him to make a bad song I say
he's so [__] dope he's just such a
talented and and such a good dude it
seems super super sweet guy you know
what I mean um can you did you guys cuz
I again I'm not I I you I told you this
off the off the air I was never like a
big fan of your guys's music but I'm
very aware of you guys and your your
Universe you know did you get twisted
ever squash your guys' uh the Civil War
of the the the jugal world no [__]
Twisted I the day I die really yeah [__]
them [__] them [__] them I ain't never
been betrayed harder in my life it was
it was a [__] physical pain the way
those [__] betrayed me cuz you
guys did put them on like literally gave
them gave them a fan base right I gave
them the name right they didn't have
paint on they were two other rappers you
know what I mean we signed them put the
paint on created them you know what I'm
saying they got insane Talent you know
what I'm saying but we created that you
know what I'm saying like it was it was
what was the Betrayal fact that they
left you know they they were dropping
end bombs everywhere in um in the RS
like you know what I mean and we're like
what the [__] are y'all doing you know
what I mean we had to
[__] hone them in you know what I'm
saying cuz they're talented as [__] they
were talented as [__] you know we had to
hone them in and they're just dumb and
and wild style you know but we [__]
showed them how to do it showed them how
to market showed them all that [__] you
know what I'm saying and and BR them on
tour the first time we ever built
ourselves up to go on a national tour on
a bus they were in the [__]
opening you know what I'm saying we just
gave them love I at first The Jug the
jugglers were like when they came out
two guy two other guys in clown paint
the juggers were
like [__] you you know what I'm
saying you know what I'm saying and we
took us years you know what I mean for
them to accept them yeah man we were
like these are our boys we're putting
them Psychopathic you know what I mean
and still people couldn't understand the
idea of Jugo being something different
than ICP right they didn't want to bring
then you guys had like and it was a fat
kindy of skinny guy just like me you
know I mean it's like what the [__] and
then a lot of your guys' artist ended up
with face paint blaz your Dead Homie and
anybody killer a that's what I'm saying
we we did our label like a wrestling
yeah brother we created characters we
were like all right Blaze what what does
Blaze do you know Blaze is from back in
the day with when they wore the clock
you know what I'm saying and Raiders
[__] and everything and he got killed
and now he's supposed to be current
rapping that old [__] that was our idea
back then you know what I'm saying and
um and then uh anybody kill up right he
was native right yeah I was like what do
you uh what's your uh her what what what
is your ethnicity whatever and he was
like I'm native and I'm like rep that
because yo the natives love love y'all I
told I told him rep that yeah you know
what I'm saying in all your [__] you
know and and we just helped these
[__] and signed them and BR
them on tour and paying all these ninjas
to open for us in front of our own Crow
right right right right I'm [__]
paying these [__] all my life
it was like 10 years 15 years I think 16
years I I did that wit Twisted you know
what I'm saying paying them you know so
was the Betrayal the fact that they left
the label you know what the problem was
bro when they got bigger in the jugal
world and jugal loved them yeah because
they they became really big right IP
come to town and draw 2500 or something
on on a good night
right have them on a tour we do the same
thing same tickets exactly but we're
paying them all this money you know it
was that like that forever mhm that but
we we loved them right you know what I'm
saying then there was a group called um
Axe Murder boys right and um they won a
contest we like had a contest and [__]
to see who were going to sign you know
they won a contest Twisted was like [__]
them you know what I mean they won the
contest they were like they feel why
they they want a contest they don't
deserve to be here [__] them they
wouldn't even twisty wouldn't even let
them come in the studio oh wow right so
the the uh one guy in in a murder boy
young Wicked he was like um he had like
a hatred for Twisted after that you know
so years later when Twisted starts their
own label and all that you know what I
mean they signed him huh did they sign
that guy okay no the guy at the I
remember at the Gathering at the Young
Wicked show he's like all I got to say
is psychopathic for life [__] that other
noise everybody knew exactly what he was
talking about you know the whole crowd
and [__] and um then
um so when when uh we got betrayed that
[__] they that when that dude
that dude young Wicked he was my he was
my uh Protege prot yeah he was my
producer I'm putting them M yeah I love
that kid so much I was
like it's my goal I'm sorry let me take
a drink do your
thing I said I never said this for
anybody I said it's my goal to see you
and your family in living in a paid off
house in Detroit all right with
significant money in the bank that's my
goal right that's what we were working
toward for him because he had his two
kids out there and his girl was pregnant
again you know what I'm saying and that
was his dream to move them here you know
what I'm saying and he wanted to live in
Detroit you know what I'm saying that
[__] got my brother daughter
pregnant you know what I'm saying and
betrayed the [__] hell out of
all of us your brother's daughter yeah
how old was she she was uh of age you
know she was of age okay but um still
that's crazy bro he denied it he denied
it he denied it well he got my brother
told me man it
was no what happened was my brother's
daughter told my
brother hey I've been messing around
with uh young Wicked and my brother was
like what and so my brother didn't tell
none of us cuz at the time he's got a
pregnant girl too or he has got family
I'm saying that he worships and puts his
[__] on in front of us you know so my
brother's own daughter tells him hey
I've been with young Wicked you know so
my brother pulls that [__] in in
the room in the office you know what I
mean just him and he's
like stay the [__] away from my daughter
you know what I'm saying she ain't your
local peace my brother's a d at
Psychopathic you know what I'm saying
there's four of us me my brother Joey
and Billy my my brother is a Don and
this [__] and my brother said
I'm not going to tell anybody what you
did you know what I'm saying not going
to tell
anybody stay the [__] away from my
daughter you know what I'm saying that's
crazy so a month later my brother's
daughter tells him she's still seeing
them you know what I'm saying oh so my
brother had to tell us and it was
like you know so listen all that
happened right when Twisted in our fell
out when you guys had your yeah right
and [__] they signed him the next
like the the day Rob let us know you
guys dropped them there was a picture
the next day him with them like this it
was insane they hated each other for
years yeah they didn't even want him in
the studio until they had something in
common and that was [__] y' [__] yeah
on us and it was insane bro these were
my my gu my your prot like you said
anyway I [__] all that you know yeah
[__] them all man [__] all that [__]
anybody killer all of them [__]
Blaze all them [__] can [__]
the [__] off I hate them so it's safe to
say there'll never be another dark I
never think about them I don't I don't I
didn't see I see I'm like I said like
I'm I'm aware of you and twisted issues
I didn't know you had issues with
everybody else